that I actually went to see the pyramids
because of you I'm very glad to hear
that it was uh it was a mind-bending
experience and when was that this is God
what exactly was this four years ago
pandemic kind of makes things there's
like three a little murky maybe three
but it was pre-bendable plateau and
those those three massive pyramids and
the satellite pair is an amazing place
and the Great Pyramid itself is totally
utterly unique extraordinary and and
special I have a I have a long
relationship with the Great Pyramid I
saw I saw this unbelievable
story of you going to the top I tried to
get I got like a quarter of the way up
by myself and I was there with my wife
and I was like I'm not trying to get
arrested yeah and have her just be alone
in Egypt and so I put it out and I went
back down probably a wise decision
because you could have spent some year
or two in jail wow really oh yeah yeah
wow did you get locked up when you went
up top no the the the illegal climbs
that we did the first the first illegal
climb involved four o'clock in the
morning and a lot of bribery
um how much how much was it back in the
day together this was like 1996 might
even have been earlier it might have
been 1994. and um we had we had a local
guy who made contact with all the guards
around the pyramid we paid him money I
forget the exact amount he said he'd
paid them off but then when we got to
the base of the pyramid we had to walk
all the way around it which is a
considerable distance 750 feet along
each side we had to walk all the way
around and then we had to add more money
to each of the guards at the Four
Corners
um and then we went up happen my advice
to anybody who's climbing the Great
Pyramid which is pretty much impossible
these days either legally or legally as
go up the southwest corner because the
southwest corner is pretty intact it's
pretty much a straight line you can
follow it all the way to the to the what
is the entrance on North Side that's
North yeah so South yeah
Southwest yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah which
is the opposite side to the Great Sphinx
and um and then nobody's looking at you
well it's it's good for that they're all
facing
we were a few courses up but another
guard turned up with a shotgun I don't
think it would have reached us from that
distance but there were threats and we
had to promise to pay him more more
money so he points the shotgun yeah kind
of threatening you yeah you guys go
we'll pay you and he's like okay well
now you can basically yeah we did a deal
that we'd pay him when we came down and
did you yeah we did yeah okay yeah yeah
it's good to keep your promises and then
and then we climb we climb how much you
paid I actually don't
um but but back in back in the day
um 19 I guess it was probably 1994. it
would have seemed a lot to me at that
time but it also but it also seemed
seemed worth it it was a fantastic
Adventure uh starting starting in the in
in the dark or the just the beginning of
dawn light and and you know climbing up
to the top taking shelter at various
points behind bits as as other guards
appeared finally getting finally getting
to the top
um and then the light coming up and just
this Majestic Majestic View Sunrise yeah
the sunrise Atop The Great Pyramid and
the second pyramid you know to yourself
it's just an amazing it's an amazing
thing to see and it's an amazing
experience I would regard it as one of
the peak experiences of My Life
um I did have one other illegal climb
which was just fortunate it was
um following the the holiday of Ramadan
they have um they have a thing called
the Eid which is a celebration and they
were I would guess there were 30 000
kyrenees on the Giza Plateau having
picnics and they just decided they were
going to climb the Great Pyramid not all
30 000 but several hundred of them and
we just joined them me and Santa and we
and we climbed we climbed with them and
that's one that actually is one of the
moments when I realized how difficult
the Great Pyramid must have been to
build because because the biggest danger
climbing up there with several hundred
people on the pyramid was other people
coming up and down so imagine managing
that with all the blocks with all the
blocks and and supposedly a huge
Workforce and ramps or whatever the
egyptologists imagined was done and I
don't believe anybody knows how it was
done uh for me that was the the biggest
risk was people bumping into you people
going around you as you as you climb as
you're climbing up
um but again we we got to the top and
then I had three legal climbs in those
days when those were allowed doing
various filming projects back in when do
you see your last name inscribed in the
block I think this is an incredible
story yes it is I think it was I think
it was on the second
or third climb I'm not absolutely sure I
think it may have been one of the legal
type claims because it was Daylight and
we were relaxed uh as we were not when
there were hundreds of other people up
there with us so I think it may have
been it may have been one of the legal
crimes and and there I did see and it's
on the south side of the uh of of the
Great Pyramid the South the the the
southeast side overlooking the Boat
Museum which used to be there
um and there was the name
um initial p and Hancock
um and at that time
there was a date beside it and that date
if I recall correctly was the 5th of
April 1916.
um oddly enough 1916. yeah now my my
granddad was was a chaplain with British
forces
um in Egypt in the first world war so I
had to consider the possibility that it
could be him he was called Philip
Hancock oh wow um but I couldn't
absolutely guarantee that and and I was
able to confirm it by by finding my
grandfather's Diaries
um which were little diaries about that
tiny little writing in them and um on
that date the the there was a single
line which said climb Great Pyramid
today
and then I found it was dated in 1916.
yeah yeah and then I found his uh his
biography which was passed down to me by
by my dad and
um he also talks about his climb of the
Great Pyramid in that although in very
spare terms doesn't doesn't say that
much about it when I mean I know it's
not that much that he put in there but
did he say it was there was any security
at that time rearranged
totally free range and I think the sound
was definitely cleared away at that time
but but anybody could climb the Great
Pyramid and and there was in fact the
guy who organized our first illegal
climate I think I can say this safely
because he's passed on to the next world
was a guy known locally as champion and
he was called champion because he was
the champion Runner of the Great Pyramid
he could run all the way to the top of
the Great Pyramid there were times
people did that and it was totally legal
and nobody nobody objected to it at all
um and that went on I think
certainly through the sort of 70s and
80s but by the time my wife Santa and I
climbed 1994 for the first time I'm
pretty sure it was 94.
um it had become it had become illegal
and now it's totally illegal it's it's
completely banned yeah and I don't I
doubt even if a film crew would get
permission to climb to climb the Great
Pyramid now even like that yeah they
they
um
they're very careful about it but and
one of the reasons why they're careful
about it is that every year at least one
person dies a client trying to climb the
Great Pyramid uh people still try to
climb it illegally and and as you can
imagine from the bit of the climb you
did you're looking at a 52 degree slope
yeah so once you get up once you get up
100 150 feet above the ground if you
lose it and fall it's over you're going
to go all the way to the bottom yeah and
it's over here in the beginning you have
a lot of confidence the first few tiers
of of rocks seem pretty easy they're not
too bad but I can imagine you're halfway
up and you start looking down and it is
over if you slip totally over and also
the the the the course sizes vary uh
some of the some of them are really no
more than sort of hip-high some of some
of the courses are chest high so you've
got to horses are the blocks yeah I mean
the it's laid out in layers so you know
it looks like a step pyramid now it
looks considered it wasn't before in
ancient times it was covered with facing
stones and you can see some of the
facing some of the phases stones are
still there down at the bottom of the
Great Pyramid they give you a sense of
how beautiful they were and how and and
how magnificently well it was made but
the theory is there's no absolute proof
of this that they came off during an
earthquake in I believe 1301. uh and at
that time it's likely that that's when
the Great Pyramid lost its Summit Great
Pyramid stands at the moment about 450
maybe 455 feet tall but its original
height was 481 feet tall and you can
calculate that from just pursuing the
slope of the size up to them 30 feet
came off yeah yeah so it's a there's a
flat platform or rather even a stepped
platform on top of the Great Pyramid
with with one level and then one level
of another level but the calculation is
very simple you just you just pursue
those side lengths up to where they
would meet
um according to that calculation the
Great Pyramid was originally 481 feet
tall wow
um so it lost it lost uh about 30 feet
the question is was it in fact ever
completed we don't know that for sure
right the general view is that that
earthquake brought part of the top of
the Great Pyramid tumbling down as well
and knocked off the face concerns and
then of course it was used as a quarry
that's that's what I heard yeah because
it's very very useful to have all this
nice Cut Stone yeah around and and a lot
of those facing stars were taken away
okay so
after inspiring probably tens of
thousands of people to go to the
pyramids like myself you managed to get
banned from Egypt yes is it a real
full-time ban this this is this is not
clear to me we were we got to sneak in
in my my we gotta we gotta do one more
time there's a champion Junior though we
need a carve G Hancock right next I
think this would be good it's it's very
uh it's very difficult to do that with a
film crew however this is when and this
is when and this is when it happened uh
is that we my Netflix series ancient
apocalypse we wanted to film an episode
in Egypt which you would have thought
the Egyptian authorities would welcome
um but when when they asked who is
presenting the show and we said that
Graham Hancock is presenting the show
they said they said absolutely no way
and they they would not they would not
Grant filming permission let me tell you
Sandra the Four Seasons in Cairo wants
you to do an episode about the pyramids
I promise you yeah it would it would
bring a lot of interest and a lot of
people but there's a rigid fixed view
amongst egyptologists about the
prehistory and the history of ancient
Egypt questioning that questioning that
gets you back okay that's the first
that's the first line of defense against
the critic or an alternative point of
view yes is simply to deny them access
to the side and I yeah I felt since that
happened that I've had my left arm cut
off yeah because Egypt has been very
Central and very important to my work I
I hope eventually I will I will get back
in could I go as a tourist maybe right
uh maybe but uh definitely not filming
it definitely not filming when you did
the legal Clines were they aware you had
did the two illegal crimes previously
yeah oh and they still gave you
permission uh yeah oh wow at that time
at that time everything was much less
sensitive everything was much less
sensitive until 2015 when uh when I had
uh the beginnings of a public debate
with um who is regarded as the leading
Egyptian egyptologist
and unfortunately in that debate zahi
it's it's actually on YouTube bits of it
because there was a member of the
audience present uh zahi massively lost
his temper and stormed out
um and then uh so you won then I well I
don't know but the the debate didn't
happen then I gave a talk he sat sulking
outside then he came back gave his talk
then the audience asked questions and
again bits of this were filmed and one
of the audience asked him if he knew
about a site called Gobekli Tepe in
Turkey which is probably the most
important archaeological site in the
world at the moment and zahi said that
he didn't know anything about it at all
and that was on camera so unfortunately
the man is actually enormously
knowledgeable about ancient Egypt but
but unfortunately he came across looking
not very good and and ever since then my
relationship with him which had been
okay until 2015 has been extremely
negative and and when the Egyptian
government are approached for filming
permission which these days is done
through the tourism and Antiquities
permission when their approach for the
film information zahi is the guy they go
to and say is it okay for these people
to come in and film so yeah
then it's not going to happen it's it's
difficult and I understand the
defensiveness because when you wrap your
cultural identity around something or
creating something as Majestic as the
pyramids feeling as if that's like being
ripped away from you can really make you
feel as if your identity is being taken
yeah and to be clear I would I would
never wish to divorce the Great Pyramids
from the ancient Egyptians